amd's RX 6950xt is almost a totally
different class of GPU compared to when
it first launched to tepid reviews
earlier this year and with recent price
adjustments it is such a good deal now
that its green opponent no longer makes
any sense and neither does its
predecessor the 6900 XT
but why am I talking about the 6000
series because however the RX 7900
series performs today and it's good I
want you to also keep in mind amd's
track record for dramatically improving
the performance of their gpus through
new features and Driver optimizations
personally I'm counting on it because
now that I have publicly committed to
skipping nvidia's latest 40 series cards
AMD is my only hope for an upgrade this
generation
just like my only hope of paying our
production team is our sponsor PDQ
automate patch management and software
updates with PDQ search your library of
over 200 ready to deploy applications
and install software zero touch from
your disk start your free trial at
pdq.com LTT
right out of the gate the 7900 series is
full of upgrades it features amd's brand
new rdna 3 architecture up to 24
gigabytes of much higher bandwidth gddr6
memory substantially boosted core clocks
across the board and this is great the
step down 7900 XT comes with as many
compute units as amd's previous Flagship
with the beefier XTX rocking even more
despite having more and faster cores
though one of amd's boldest claims is
that they've managed to improve
efficiency by 54 this is thanks in large
part to amd's high bandwidth chiplet
design the first of its kind in a modern
GPU what's more they've beefed up their
Ray accelerator cores for real-time
raytraced Lighting in supported games
and finally included AI accelerator
cores to bring Radeon to feature parody
with Nvidia and Intel's offerings
unlike those offerings however the
Radeon RX 7900 series cards we're
looking at today come equipped with
DisplayPort 2.1 which enables support
for up to 8K
165 Hertz displays is that even
necessary who cares it's awesome
and it's something that nvidia's top-end
GPU the RTX 4090 cannot do in spite of
its staggering sixteen hundred dollar
sticker price
all of this is while actually fitting in
your case and costing 900 and a thousand
dollars for the XT and the XTX
respectively that is 200 to 300 less
than the RTX 4080 that AMD says they
should be able to compete with for Speed
Of course we won't be taking their word
for that AMD has been known to be
optimistic at 4K it's clear out of the
gate and Shadow of the Tomb Raider that
whatever team red fans might have hoped
for the RX 7900 XTX is not amd's answer
to the RTX 4090 it's got performance
that is realistically more in line with
the 4080 though that is what AMD said
and this pattern continues in Hitman
cyberpunk 2077 and Modern Warfare 2.
well great right I mean why did I spend
all that time talking about the
importance of amd's ongoing driver
developments keep that in mind well
there's this for one thing Forza Horizon
5 is a clear loss for team red thanks to
those subpar one percent and five
percent low frame rates but also this
for another reason that right there is a
one thousand dollar GPU beating a
sixteen hundred dollar GPU in F1 2022
and if the results I'm looking at right
now are any indication of the kind of
raw power that amd's driver team has on
tap here there is some serious aging
like fine wine potential on the table
of course you should never buy a promise
though and today amd's best Trails
nvidia's best by about 17 which sounds
bad Until you realize that nvidia's card
costs 60 percent more compared to the
4080 the XTX is a no-brainer at nine
percent faster and 20 cheaper and the
7900 XT does even better I mean sure the
4080 is seven percent faster but costs
33 percent more
1440p doesn't always show us a
difference compared to 4K but here we do
see some strange behavior in Forza that
we retested several times the 7000
series is actually slower than amd's
older 6000 series cards we think this
could be a problem with the game as it's
the only one out of our suite that does
it and when we went to test for it says
Ray tracing performance we saw that it
was in fact pretty broken we also see
the RTX 4080 pull ahead of even the XTX
in Shadow of the Tomb Raider and Red
Dead Redemption which is especially
surprising considering that virtually
every other game shows AMD closing the
Gap instead the biggest example is in
Modern Warfare 2 where the minimum frame
rates aren't quite up to the level of
the RTX 4090 but the average frame rates
are which again can set some potential
for optimization in total these numbers
put the 7900 Series in a very good
position to compete with nvidia's 40
series to the point where if traditional
rasterized gaming was all that existed
Nvidia would need to lower their prices
but it isn't all that exists and Ray
tracing is sadly still not amd's strong
suit while substantially better in
cyberpunk than the rx6000 series these
7000 series gpus are behind Nvidia by at
least a factor of two at 4K at 1440p AMD
at least manages to break the 30 FPS
minimum Mark making the game playable
and you can use FSR to render at a lower
resolution and upscale for smooth
gameplay but at that point we could also
do the same thing for Team Green and the
overall story would still be the same
F1 2022 fares slightly better for AMD at
least with the 7900 XTX pulling up to
within 16 percent of the RTX 4080 in
minimum frame rates and actually near
parity on average which again gives me
hope that some of amd's woes with Ray
tracing are a matter of optimization and
that feeling only grows with shadow of
the Tomb Raider where even at 4K it's
within about 12 percent of the 4090 and
turning out nearly 60 FPS it is an older
game but that's not bad it's just that a
good race ran when the other guy ran
faster is still an l and ultimately the
RX 7900 XTX just couldn't even come
close to the RTX 4080s level of
performance with Ray tracing enabled I
suspect that most people myself included
still don't use Ray tracing often and
won't really be affected but given that
these things do still cost a thousand
flipping dollars it's definitely a skid
mark on what has otherwise been a pretty
good showing so far and I'm afraid
there's more where that came from the
professionals who have need of this kind
of graphical horsepower will be well
disappointed isn't quite the right word
but looking at these numbers they're not
going to be excited either yes blender
runs a good eight to twenty percent
faster on the 7000 versus the 6000
series but Nvidia walks all over amd's
entire stack at between three to four
times the performance thankfully amd's
new encoding engine helps them push
ahead of the RTX 4080 in DaVinci Resolve
in both h.264 and especially h.265 which
their encoding engine seems to favor
that's a good 20 more speed for the XTX
there not bad though the 49d does remain
on top procyon video and photo are also
pretty good for AMD with performance
that I would call comparable it's within
a few percentage points either way you
look at it and rounding out the video
editing Suite is topaz AI which despite
the name is using GPU compute here
rather than any AI course and wow even
the 7900 XT outperforms the RTX 4090
here this workload seems to heavily
favor amd's Infinity cash as the 6000
series cards aren't too shabby either
specvperf brings AMD about as many wins
as losses but the degree to which the
7000 series wins over the competition is
often much lower than the losses that
they suffer with especially poor results
in 3ds Max Maya and SolidWorks which
even dip under the performance of the
6000 series that's pretty rough those
are kind of important applications they
pull off major wins in Catia Creo energy
medical and especially Siemens NX though
as we've said in the past this is
because the version in specview perf
doesn't support Hardware acceleration on
Nvidia and actually this is just going
to be excluded from our averages when we
calculate it later on spec workstation
Paints the radons in a significantly
better light though with product
development life sciences and energy all
pushing well past Team Green but media
and entertainment as well as GPU compute
still stay with Nvidia likely thanks to
opencl's relative obscurity next to Cuda
despite the blows the 7900 series car
cards took though their beefed up media
engines and GPU compute horsepower
placed them with an average of two to
ten percent of Team Green given the wide
performance spread we saw depending on
the workload potential prospective
professional people will want to think
long and hard about which capabilities
are most important to them before making
a final decision changing gears a little
we found something interesting when we
were testing resizable bar on both Intel
and AMD platforms it seems like the
performance improvements regardless of
whether you have a team blue or team red
CPU can be expected to be pretty similar
despite AMD heavily marketing smart
access memory as a selling point for the
ryzen plus Radeon ecosystem bear in mind
that this is a sample size of just two
games but without resizable bar we're
figuring you can expect anywhere from a
10 to 35 percent reduction in
performance regardless of which side you
swing for as for amd's updated video
encoder there's a lot to be excited
about here av1 support and baked in
machine learning to improve quality at
the top of my list but despite receiving
our cards early we actually only had a
few days to test these things prior to
embargo because we didn't have a driver
so we were forced to push our image
quality comparisons to a separate video
that you can expect to see in the next
couple of weeks
one of amd's other selling points is its
smaller footprint compared to nvidia's
40 series gpus and I was concerned that
this would come at the expense of
thermals so I was extremely pleased to
see that amd's new cooler design has the
7000 series actually performing better
than the 6000 series with that said
though AMD does not have the luxury of
only competing with themselves and
Nvidia is clearly in the better position
here though with that said both of the
Nvidia cards we tested have
substantially larger heatsinks with fan
off modes while amd's new cards always
ran their fans it's probable that
designs from the likes of Asus or power
color will run much cooler and hopefully
quieter
now we need to talk about core clocks
because they're a little different this
generation thanks to the decoupling of
the front end and the Shader clocks the
idea here is that the front end will
benefit more from higher clocks while
the more numerous Shader units crunch
data in parallel at a lower clock speed
resulting in a better balance of
performance and efficiency and you can
see that in action here where both the
7900 XTX and XT have a consistent 200
megahertz gap between the two clocks and
even in a power virus like MSI combustor
these clocks remained higher than the
previous generation clock stability in
game is similar to the 6000 series cards
but nvidia's 40 series manages flatter
lines throughout the Run suggesting that
AMD is trying to be pretty aggressive
with managing power consumption
which makes sense because AMD talked a
lot about performance per watt in their
marketing and looking at these in-game
paragraphs no
that seems to suggest that their
self-congratulations are well Justified
the Radeon RX 7900 XTX Drew comparable
power to the 4080 and this held even
when we hit it with MSI combustor the XT
was even better still staying in line
with its predecessor but what's
interesting is when we take a magnifying
glass to how many watts the 7000 series
poles per frame in this example while
the raw wattage drops much closer to the
RTX 4080 when we capped the frame rate
to 100 the total watts per frame
increases substantially this suggests
that while the RTX 4080 is able to
throttle itself effectively AMD is
actually having some trouble with power
management and amd's idle power
consumption numbers seem to corroborate
this where the RTX 4080 idles at around
15 to 20 watts the 7900 XTX regularly
sucks Back 40 and sometimes over 50
Watts while doing nothing at all what's
even more baffling is that we noticed
what seems like a major bug during our
testing depending on the monitor that we
plugged into the GPU we saw a wildly
different total system power at the wall
from a respectable 52 Watts with nothing
plugged in to a whopping
171 Watts with our 27 inch Rog Swift
bench display using some other monitors
even caused performance to drop now
given that I have a high-end display and
I live in Vancouver Canada where energy
is the one thing that is still cheap
none of this is a deal breaker for me
but if I was in Europe where Energy
prices had surged pun intended it would
give me pause before I was willing to
look at team red adding insult to injury
this high idle power draw means that the
fans are spinning at all times kicking
that heat out into your room even if
you're just scrolling Reddit meaning
that the 7900 series is going to be a
little less comfortable to live with
maybe if you go team red you could pick
up a blank T rather than a retro polar
fleece from ltdstore.com space heater
one possible explanation for this high
idle power consumption could be that
this is a similar situation to the ryzen
7 5800 X 3D that cpu's use of 3D V cash
limited its stability if voltages
weren't dialed in just right and we
could be witnessing similar teething
issues with this new chiplet
architecture and supporting that theory
is the fact that the driver straight up
locks out power adjustments below 90
percent of total board power when we
asked them about this AMD played pretty
Coy with us which tells us either we're
right or that they're not sure either
now it's time to talk about what this
data means for the GPU Market first of
all anyone who was hoping that the 7900
series would come in and compete head to
head against the RTX 4090 will be sorely
disappointed at least for today we saw a
brief glimpses of Glory but the RTX 4090
remains on its Throne making it tough to
dislodge its price from that TI Titan
perch that it currently occupies as a
Halo product but while AMD doesn't have
a direct competitor to it I still think
the 7900 XTX is a much better value
as for the RTX 4080 well the comparison
gets a little more complicated even the
XT model comes really close in
traditional rendering and the value
proposition of either 7900 GPU is a
damning indictment of nvidia's pricing
but AMD does remain on the back foot in
Ray tracing performance and that's
something that Nvidia can point to and
claim makes up the difference even if
nobody seriously cares it'll take people
like me running out and buying 7900
series cards instead of 40 series to
make Nvidia realize that they're out to
lunch
but wait why are we saying this now you
might think we took a lot of flack for
covering for nvidia's pricing in the RTX
4080 review didn't we well not so much
first off we compared it to cards that
were available at the time it released
and we ended the video with a message to
wait for our dna3 and we're reviewing
the 7900 Series in much the same way
second it had already been made known
that the RX 7900 XTX was not going to
compete with the 4090 which depending on
how you look at it means that either the
RTX 4080 is actually a 90 class card and
priced accordingly with the 490 being a
TI or something or the 7900 XT and XTX
are the current gen equivalent of the
6800 and 6800 XT and are themselves
overpriced basically it's kind of a game
of pick your Villain at this point
because the reality is that 600 top of
the line gpus are a thing of the past
and that was an assumption that our
review made but did not fully explain
it's worth pointing out by the way since
I'm being a downer right now anyway that
while AMD supports DisplayPort 2.1 and
nvidia's 40 series does not AMD went
with a half measure by supporting only
the uhbr 13.5 spec what this means is
that it can only achieve its lofty
resolution and frame rate support
through display stream compression DSC
allows up to three times more bandwidth
than is both near zero latency and
Visually lossless though that doesn't
mean that there is no quality loss
practically speaking this won't be a
problem even if it were noticeable given
that these gpus aren't really capable of
pushing those resolutions and frame
rates anyway but we brought it up with
the RTX 40 series so we're bringing it
up here for the sake of completeness it
means that those new 8K ultrawide
displays being shown up at CES will just
barely be able to run at 85 Hertz
without DSC but I would never expect
that to be a problem for an actual user
one slightly problematic thing that I do
need to address is that we've taken a
very glass half full approach today and
I can understand why some of you might
be frustrated by it we've gone and spun
amd's potential future driver
improvements as a good thing when
actually they're kind of bad another
perspective is that it means that AMD is
releasing these products even though
they haven't really finished optimizing
them and if you've kind of felt that way
up to this point I totally get where
you're coming from we ran into some kind
of bizarre no really bizarre crashes and
there are certainly features that could
be added or refined but In fairness to
our charitable approach today AMD is
pricing these gpus according to what
they are now and their track record for
fixing these things is actually pretty
good even if sometimes it takes a while
as they focus on new features like FSR
3.0 and the hyper RX performance
Optimizer that have yet to Launch and if
this is where performance is now with
some of what broken certainly
unoptimized drivers AMD clearly has some
great Hardware on their hands here they
even brought back the USBC Port
something that is great for hooking up a
monitor via a single cable and a godsend
for enthusiasts like myself I'm still
mad that Nvidia removed it after the 20
series
so the RX 7900 XTX is going into my
gaming rig and I'm officially switching
to team red for the first time since the
3870.
goodness gracious
the performance is good enough the price
is good enough well at least compared to
the competition and the downsides are
small enough that I am comfortable
making the leap just like I'm gonna
comfortably leap to this Segway from our
sponsor MSI and their recently released
mag z790 Tomahawk Wi-Fi motherboard the
mag 790 Tomahawk is a gaming oriented
ATX motherboard that balances value with
premium Hardware it's built around the
latest Intel z790 chipset which supports
12th and 13th gen Intel core processors
with dual 8-pin power connectors and
core boost technology is able to sustain
heavy CPU power loads to better support
demanding game settings it also features
m.2 Shield frozer msi's Advanced thermal
solution which offers great protection
for maximum SSD transfer speed
performance with integrated options for
multiple cooling methods the z790
tomahawk ensures Optimal Performance
when you need it the most make sure to
check it out at the link in the video
description if you enjoyed this and
you're looking for something else to
watch maybe go check out that Arc 30 day
challenge video I mentioned Intel's
doing some really good things over there
but they also have a lot of work to do